bonjour bonsoir bosu vous voyez
steve kaufman steve kaufman ici je
vais voyager en france étiqueté
foss je pars jeudi soir je vais
voyager principalement sur mon affaire de bois mais
jihad yonghong continos suis imam du
lien madame hamamoto  lien peut dijon ddm
après une journée ap quelque part oncle
téléthon à Joe VA le 30 janvier se
rencontrer sur appelé Apache un lollicock
n'est pas un TI SE ven dkc poursuivre le moine analicia
youtube p 0 wat pho van agua donc si
vous êtes intéressé laissez  je sais et nous
trouverons un endroit bien je la société n'a pas l'
occasion de klaxonner déjà le junkie sin
ti si longtemps alors j'ai hâte d'avoir
de vos nouvelles d'ailleurs je vais être au
Mexique du 26 février au
13 mars  les sept ou huit premiers jours
à San Miguel de Allende et guanajuato
qui n'est pas très loin de Guadalajara je
peux y prendre un bus podemos
encontrarnos agua la jara entre ellos
saben TCA digamos la primera semana de
marzo y despues seria en la ciudad de
mexico  yo non  se el día es esta el tres a
de marzo entonces podemos tambien
encontrarnos en la tio de mexico
entonces si amigos mexicanos que viven
ocn valla ha no se en la ciudad de
mexico por favor que indica que solo los
gatos a que podemos tratar de organizer
la  una una encuentro en cual ahora un
otro en
not your amigo mucho gusto merci
beaucoup agréable de discuter avec vous tous ici
via de su méthode de
communication unilatérale donc j'espère qu'à Paris
et éventuellement au Mexique nous aurons
plus d'occasions de bavarder en retour
et-vient dans différentes langues
merci d'avoir écouté au revoir pour l'instant